[Music]
economy plus
oh for the discerning passenger
[Music]
we're not in kansas anymore
khatto
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding
south northern airlines flight 34 to
grand rapids
excuse me boarding group one i'm gonna
board a group one excuse me i'm
importing group one and
we would like to begin pre-boarding with
our first class passengers first class
passengers only please
next our business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
regal alliance elite members
regal alliance elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you may board
now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel
what why could this is thank you for
your service
thank you so much for your service god
bless you thank you for your service
thank you for your service all right
people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imams
what why do they get special treatment
asalam alaikum
i've never that's typical
any old people in wheelchairs with
babies
[Music]
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
thank you for your service
jason schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board
finally no not you sir not me
this is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
god damn it anyone who doesn't seem
cranky
drunk people who will now be boarding
any drunk
people drunk people
nope it's my bag
ooh hello
oh hey christian yeah
totally well you have your favorites and
i have my favorites
okay call you later
morning group one
[Music]
i got him i got schwartzman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get a boarding group one
[Music]
he talks too much that's why i like you
you don't talk you just listen it's good
and the captain has turned on the fasten
seat belt sign got a little turbulence
coming up should be no problem just
remain in your seat until the sign is
turned off thank you for your
cooperation
okay
excuse me i'm gonna go to the bathroom
hi excuse me yeah yeah
i need you to take your seat the fasten
seatbelt sign is on yeah i'm just gonna
go to the bathroom for a second i'll be
right back okay
i understand what you want to do uh
unfortunately i'm gonna need you to
observe the fasten seatbelt sign that'd
be much appreciated
right just i read on the internet that
it's not against the law for me to go to
the bathroom while the fast and seat
belt sign is on
so see about sign but is it against the
law though
the light is on is against the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on that side no but is it against
the law though the fascinating thought
but is it against sir
what is it against the seatbelt sign is
on but is it against the bell sign but
is it against the law it's only
time
the toilet can you lower your voice i
have to piss and i have to
okay lower your intensity you're louder
than me you're yelling
you're in my face sorry you're the one
who i think needs to tone it down right
now
you are screaming at me you're hurting
my eardrums
that wasn't a word you're not saying a
word this is a word
that's not that's not a word that's a
tongue trick
okay sir sir sir if you would like i
would not like to
i would not like to sit down what i'd
like to do
is go take the bathroom
because it's not against
the law so i'm gonna go to the bathroom
okay mark
with a k
uh
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
oh
your captain has turned off the fasten
seatbelt sign feel free to move around
the cabin
thank you for your
excuse cooperation oh excuse me sir are
you sitting in 26g
yes have i done something wrong no no no
we just wanted to ask if you would mind
switching seats so that a mother and a
child could sit together
but i'm back there
right yeah but you'd actually be sitting
here
[Music]
which is an economy plus um it's
actually an upgrade
upgrade you say
economy plus yes sir oh
don't mind if you do great great uh
carry on
carry on yourself alex thank you
[Music]
economy plus for the discerning
passengers
[Music]
we're not in kansas anymore
ladies and gentlemen this is your
captain speaking we should be leaving
topeka in the next 10 minutes
i stand corrected looks like we're gonna
have a smooth flight
trust me i know the captain and he's one
smooth guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course he knows the captain he is the
captain
oh oh
move over colin mockery there's a new
face in the biz
his name is captain
we have to be an economy plus to cut it
i guess
[Music]
extra foot room one inch at least
[Music]
oh dog ears from my convenience
lord of the rings cops
lord of the rings tables
[Music]
holy shatsu massage
economy plus it hurts a little bit
but i like it
so
and i thought i had an upgrade
yo hey y'all
hon y'all
excuse excuse me oh man oh man oh man
i tell you one thing if 9 11's toward to
happen
up on this airplane
don't worry we got this okay
okay i have no idea what you're talking
about
he's saying that fdm terry's just gonna
try
some up in here today like the bounce
boogie and bump
that we got this
do you help mean baby
he ain't talking about terry guard and i
certainly ain't talking about no terry
cloth
i mean if a terry up on this plane even
thinking about trying to do
something we're gonna wax him
up you you're gonna you're gonna what
we're gonna drags
you know scouts i think what my
partner's trying to say
is if any terrorists come up in here we
gonna get our bergeron
did something happen or did i miss
something as hypothetical or
oh we're going to definitely drop some
hypotheticals on that
terry's clavicle because i'm talking
about
don't you just wish so don't you just
wish in your heart of heart
some terry would come up in here trying
some grab ass
and the touchy feely that's the opposite
of what i want to have happen on a plane
okay that's unfortunate conference
this was unexpected it certainly was
i'm thrown right now as to who's gonna
be our comrades he can still hear you
doesn't have the heart not a gumption
you're literally right next to me
oh three break three
you who i got an idea feel free to say
no
but can we switch seats i will not take
no for an answer
why that's the combat seat jonathan
livingston's ego
if you're going to be in the combat seat
then you got to be willing to blast up
on some carries
because the great power comes great
a trilogist okay i just i just wanted
some leg room
um okay max leg room
you get yours meanwhile i'm gonna go
hayden pantanieri on some terries
especially when they get froggy
ribbit baby um
you gonna have to be ready to kidnap a
terry
i don't you gonna have to be ready to
touch you a tear
i don't think that's necessary
absolutely you have to fireboard those
mother gems
i don't even understand what that means
do you trust me no i'll take that at the
yeah
okay draft these
terry's come up in here trying to act
froggy
then we going to give them the rainbow
connection
yeah won't get from getting from there
frog
box cutter oh you best believe it baby
we gonna be eating like diane keaton
2.35 inches baby [ __ ] wax
perfectly league well and if those don't
work
you know i'm working up that plan b
brother
[Music]
god oh yeah 3d printer baby
100 percent polyurethane they can't
detect these mammograms
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
drax hello
[Music]